hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar expanding bio banking size and
scope to advance Big Data discovery
presented by dr. Jennifer Koh I'm
Christie jewel of lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by Brookes
life sciences to learn more about our
sponsor please visit Brookes life
sciences comm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so just simply type
them into the ask a question box
loke located on the far left of your
screen and click send will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you have trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support tab
down at the top right of a presentation
window or your report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I now
present to you today's speaker dr.
Jennifer Cove associate Intermatic
ethology Cleveland Clinic medical
director central biorepository Cleveland
Clinic dr. Koh is a medical director of
the cleveland clinic central
biorepository housed within pathology
and Laboratory Medicine at the Cleveland
Clinic in Cleveland Ohio she is also a
derma towpath ologist with an interest
in melanoma Merkel's cell carcinoma and
tumor immunology she completed her BS MD
in the sixth year program at Northeast
Ohio Medical University she then
completed an internship at Cleveland
Clinic in internal medicine and a PhD in
immunology at Case Western Reserve
University she is boarded in anatomic
and clinical pathology and dermatology
and received all of her training at the
Cleveland Clinic
dr. Koh you may now begin your
presentation good morning everyone thank
you for the introduction today we'll be
talking about expanding biobank size and
scope with an emphasis on our experience
here at the Cleveland Clinic to advance
big data discovery so when we talk about
big data we what we mean by big data is
extremely large data sets and a lot of
the data sets are too large and complex
for traditional data processing
applications so they need to be analyzed
computationally in order to reveal
patterns trends and Association so
although big data can be thought about
multiple different contexts when we're
talking about science we mostly refer to
big data as the data surrounding
genomics so DNA sequencing are in
a sequencing and expression arrays and
the analysis of that and how do these
predict disease course so what is the
prognostic information that comes from
analyzing genomic and environmental data
and then what is the predictiveness of
this data in farce how will each patient
patient respond to treatments so big
data really helps us get more towards
personalized medicine too because when
we look at somebody's genome or their
expressions for instance in a tumor
micro-environment or in other tissues or
fluids we can predict tell that
particular person might respond to a
treatment as compared to before when we
would treat everybody the same
based on broad disease classifications
so at the Cleveland Clinic I'm going to
talk about things that we're doing to be
able to contribute to big data Cleveland
Clinic is probably the first or second
largest hospital system in the United
States as far as volume of patients
volume of surgeries complexity of
disease and so we really do want to
contribute as many samples as we can to
this type of endeavor so we'll discuss
kind of the current flash historical
state of bio banking at the Cleveland
Clinic it is a process in evolution
currently rapid evolution as we speak
and that's like current and historical
are together we'll talk a little bit
about the central biorepository in
particular which is houston pathology
and Laboratory Medicine and kind of the
future directions of the bio bank here
so historically and currently there were
several quote bio banks within the
Cleveland Clinic enterprise and The
Associated learner Research Institute
these bio banks could be surgeon owned
and really it could just be a surgeon
who bought a -80 freezer and and put
their samples residual samples if you
will in their or
it could be PhD investigators and
learner research that's the bulk of them
or MD PhD czar or MDS doing research
most of the banks are in learner
research and most of the specimens are
tracked on Excel spreadsheets some of
them have paper and we've recently done
a questionnaire to get it grip more
granular with this data and some
actually didn't even have an answer for
that question of how they're tracking
there's really no Universal lab
information system which connects all
the patient derived samples in the
Cleveland Clinic
there's no universal standard operating
procedures or freezer monitoring system
that connects all the banks in the
enterprise patient derived tissue almost
always comes through pathology which is
where the central biorepository is by
necessity because of it coming from the
operating rooms and needing to be gross
by pathology to select tissue that's
appropriate for research but it's not
necessarily tracked after it goes to a
principal investigator and rarely
tissues come from outside institutions
to the labs but but that's more rare and
patient derive fluids mostly we're
talking about blood can come from the
lab the central biorepository and
pathology it can come from Lerner
Research Institute a lot of these labs
have their own phlebotomist or outside
institutions the central biorepository
is housed within pathology and
Laboratory Medicine that's RT PLM I our
chair dr. Brian Rubin we have an
executive director and then our
pathology is split in between anatomic
pathology and clinical pathology and
really the bio bank has historically
just been in anatomic pathology because
most of what we were collecting
historically was tissue and I'm the
medical director I have a technical
director Brad Skelton we have a rotating
PA pathology assistant
who is assigned on a weekly basis to be
the biorepository PA that's off to the
right they basically need to put all the
specimens marked for for procurement
first on their priority list we have
them we look at a nightly list we look
at the o.r schedule the afternoon before
and we print out the list we give it to
the PA the PA has to know what to expect
what they're responsible for collecting
and we also note the cold ischemia time
for these samples between removal from
the patient and processing so the PA
works with the tissue procurement techs
we have far right now in the laboratory
coordinator to make sure that we collect
all the specimens as many as we can that
are targeted for collection in a timely
fashion and then we have a lab assistant
as well so our activities right now are
really and divided into three broad
categories we support clinical trials in
the toxic Cancer Institute that's all
the way to the left what that is
entailed is block and slide tissue
paraffin block and HNT glass slide
retrieval from the archives block
selection and conjunction with the
various pathologists and then cutting
and sending diagnostic material for
patients who are entering onto clinical
trials we hit that used to be run -
histology but the turnaround time was
not optimal we have a two day turnaround
time for that we also support IRB
specific research protocols most of the
pis are in the learner research
institute many of the samples that we
collect come out of the o r and get
caught and released meaning that we
procure and then we release to the PI
and we're not really tracked after it's
it's gone to that P i we just note that
it went to that p i and under here in
green it lists the number of specimens
that that were collected in each of
these categories in 2017 we're in the
process of analyzing data for 2018 and
then we have our nonspecific tissue of
fluid collections so for that we have
global iron
these the one on the left is for
de-identified non consented specimens
and the one to the right is for
consented specimens and we work with the
toxic Cancer Institute primarily - we do
have the ability to consent patients as
needed but that doesn't happen very
often when it's directed by us usually
that has to be directed by clinicians
who want to piggyback onto this broad
IRB with amendments so those are either
de-identified or consented specimens and
they are usually banked for nonspecific
future use and that could be mostly what
we target for better cancer and normal
adjacent tissues eye inflammatory bowel
disease and epilepsy because that's like
the areas that we've been asked to to
collect on now the central buyer
repository has space and surgical
pathology for tissue procurement we also
have a underneath that one floor down
our wet lab we have a processing lab
1,800 square feet we have 300 square
feet for block and slide storage and
then 784 - 80 freezers right now we have
14 minus 80 freezers and we also keep
down there things that are frozen for
diagnostic use such as direct amino
fluorescence studies which are done on
frozen tissue and are required to be
kept by cap for ten years and we monitor
all of our equipment within the bio Bank
and pathology and in all of our freezers
in pathology and Laboratory Medicine
with rece electronic monitoring lri
monitoring is variable and p.i dependent
and so that's kind of the background of
of the bio banking here
where are we going well it really got it
really took biobanking to come to the
attention of our CEO who at the time was
dr. Toby cosgrove for this to start
moving in a more futuristic direction
towards Big Data so Joe Biden who was
the vice president at the time came and
visited dr. cosgrove to discuss the
moonshot initiative at the time he you
know knowing that the cleveland clinic
is such a large-volume institution asked
what kind of clinical translational
specimens that we have that could
contribute to big data discovery and at
the time what we discover what we
realized is there's really no way to
know throughout the enterprise what we
currently are housing that was patient
derived and to quickly attach data to
that and so you know we weren't in a
position that we wanted to be to
contribute to big data and so because of
that dr. cosgrove asked to to bring
together a steering committee for a by a
broad enterprise wide biobank project
and so it really brought together the
Lerner Research Institute our chair
circle or tharam pathology and
Laboratory Medicine myself as the
medical director of the biorepository
and the center for clinical genomics who
is run by Wilson tang and we came up
with a vision that we presented to dr.
cosgrove and that's kind of what I'm
going to be drilling down on throughout
the rest of this talk but there's
several components of the biobank vision
one is recruitment and enrollment of
patients that requires a lot of
collaboration with the IRB and
mindfulness of the common role and
changes that may be coming down the
pipeline epic is the medical electronic
medical record that we use and how do we
integrate patient consent status patient
consenting into epic research orders
into epic and data how do we extract
data from epic that we can attach to bio
Bank specimens so IT informatics is huge
for that aspect
sample processing by standard procedures
throughout pathology as well as the
learner Research Institute and then a
biorepository we wanted to look for
off-site storage and it really it was
important to dr. cosgrove that we we get
a strategic partner to do that somebody
with more experience in the field to get
us up to speed more quickly which is how
we came to work with Brooks and we are
running out of space in our Research
Institute so we decided that off-site
storage with that partner would be most
advantageous and then governance for
access but this requires the engagement
of the researchers the institution the
Institute's the clinicians and the
patients and the community and so the
goals obviously are many scientifically
you know we want to give more access to
both materials and data in a common
format and reduce redundancy we want to
become eligible for more future grants
based on the organization and tracking
of these specimens we want to minimalize
physical disappearance of materials so
for example when P is leave and goes to
other institutions or lead technicians
leave or graduate students etc increase
this you know the security of the of the
patients so minimize risk of
non-compliance we want well documented
material controlled access increased
access to that material reduce operating
cross increase efficiency and basically
health care givers work to the top of
their license so this is a big lot of
goals here we thought that we would need
to phase these goals into several phases
phase one really is in the first year we
need a cold storage policy and part of
that would be to make sure that people
are tracking their samples in a
universal tracking system and that they
are cleaning out their freezers and that
they are perhaps going through be
central bio bank standard operating
procedures implemented across that goes
with the cold storage policy and
enterprise data tracking system so one
of the biggest things I think we all
recognize is that samples are never to
be housed really in one location per se
but we need them to be virtually housed
in one location electronically to allow
us to really understand what we're doing
as an enterprise and we wanted to
establish a Cleveland location for be
off storage bio bank site phase two
would be cap accreditation for the bio
Bank biospecimen evaluation and
registration so what do we currently
have what's worth keeping what's not
worth keeping and get them registered in
the Universal lift system and then
relocation of those registered freezers
and then Phase two to three would be
having the established off-site storage
reduce freezer footprint on site sample
collection with standard Universal SOPs
streamline workflow managed in
searchable samples and then that would
allow for more Industry Pharma partners
and and quite frankly other academic
institutions we've already started to
establish some of these collaborations
with other institutions and we're very
excited about that so getting back to
the vision I want to break it down into
the different components and talk more
specifically about each one so
recruitment and enrollment is really the
start where all of this starts and the
first thing that we worked on was a
universal opt-in consent we had it
approved by the IRB we thought that it
would be wise to first target all the
patients going to surgery pretty much if
you're having surgery you have
significant disease that can be
classified whether it's cancer whether
it's cardiovascular disease valvular
disease epilepsy
[Music]
you know there are several orthopedic
problems so we wanted to target all
patients going to surgery we have around
40,000 surgeries per year the Cleveland
Clinic so we reached out to surgery and
anesthesia and establish multiple points
where patients can be approached for
consent so we really want to get away
from the practice of hiring people whose
sole role is to find and consent
patients because it's just not efficient
when we look at you know some of these
research coordinators who consent
patients they could spend days just
scrubbing all the different physicians
schedules and EPIK to get to the right
ones that they want to consent and so
you know we we thought this would be a
good way to start so surgeons can
approach patients in their in their
clinics now we know that all surgeons
are not equally dedicated to research so
for the ones who are that would probably
stop there now the ones who aren't they
might get through the cracks but then
we've engaged anesthesia and we have
pace and impact clinics where patients
get cleared for pre-op surgery you know
cleared from a cardiovascular and
pulmonary standpoint so anesthesia will
have an opportunity to consent the
patients then eventually we see it going
to my chart to consent patients so then
right now as it stands in order to get
an opt-in consent approved by the IRB
Cleveland Clinic is a little bit
conservative in this way we did an
opt-in consent could not allow for extra
blood tubes it could only allow for
standard of care residual blood and
fluid and standard of care tissue which
obviously we have been doing for a long
time in pathology and currently in
pathology and this is a problem that
that we're going to need to address that
I can talk a little bit more about later
currently there's a three-day hold on
all specimens and clinical pathology
so CBC's CMPs and so forth in case that
they need to go back to those tubes and
do add-on labs but blood gases are
immediately discarded with blood gases
depending on how many there are
throughout the course of the surgery
they come in a syringe and you get about
1 mil and then 200 microliters are used
for the tests and then eight hundred
microliters are disposed of per draw so
that mostly what you can do is genomic
studies you can't really do a lot with
live blood cells but DNA studies can
also be done on on samples that have sat
for three days are any studies and and
cell viability studies what are not
possible though so we plan to collect
and pull all blood gasses worker we've
piloted this and we're in the process of
analyzing the data we we will get about
one to four MLS per patient who has
blood gases done and like I said this
will need to be modified in time
do you have a bio bank website that
we're building it will go under my
Cleveland Clinic org this will be an
access point for both patients and
investigators and it was important to
our IRB when they approve the universal
opt-in consent that we have a contact
listed on the IRB frequently asked
questions and a contact where patients
could email or call with specific
questions so the second piece of the
vision is really epic orders our
electronic medical record the data in
the electronical medical electronic
medical record and IT informatics issues
and so epic is in the process of
expanding its research module to allow
for research blood draw order placements
and to assist with targeted patient
searches and reporting for research and
so we have people who are working with
epic to to assist with that Universal
specimen storage and tracking lists so
pop out the pathology and Laboratory
Medicine central biorepository have been
using a specimen tracking system that
was supported by a company that went out
of business and so we had already
purchased lab Vantage with several
licenses for our own use at the same
time
the need was identified for an
enterprise-wide bio bank effort and we
thought that lab Vantage would fit the
bill for that and so we're in the
process now of we've implemented lab
Vantage for our own new specimen
registrations actually started in
January of this year so 2018 we've been
registering samples that we collect and
that we store in lab Vantage and now we
are onboarding the other labs and so
that has been a very interesting process
you know labs have different needs and
different
utilizations we have a team but ups on
board but I think in these early phases
we're looking to categorize labs into
categories and those categories are
still being defined based on their needs
and then doing a teach that the student
becomes the teacher to two other labs
who can assist because it's just you
know it takes a lot of people to onboard
it's not a very simple system but
because it's not simple it will be able
to fulfill all of our needs for a long
period of time so really big picture
with IT informatics is that we use the
teradata
so Teradata is a system that Cleveland
Clinic had bought separately to manage
all of its data and it's a big kind of
workhorse engine to do that so our
vision is that Terra data will be a
space where the bio bank will have its
own data lab within the terror data to
interact lab Vantage with the other
systems so the epic electronic medical
record Sun quest which is the tracking
and reporting system for clinical
pathology Cerner copass which is the
tracking and reporting system for
anatomic pathology
redcap for different labs using that to
track patients etc and we have different
data warehouses for instance in the
toxic Cancer Institute there's a cancer
data registry and we would like to be
able to interact with that so as an
example you know if we have a vest agait
tur looking for patients with with
breast cancer of a specific type we may
be able to go into lab Vantage and say
we have this many breast cancers that
have been collected and then that we
know that we have material on and then
lab managed would then send those lists
of M RNs to Co path to get all of the
staging information and the molecular
data associated with them because for
instance maybe the investigator
only wants PR PR her to negative breast
cancers so we would reach out to Co path
filter the list based on who fits that
criteria but then maybe they want to
know the eight how many of those
patients were premenopausal so then we
would be able to go into the tear into
the tumor data registry and look at
menopausal status and other pieces of
information
not that we would store duplicate that
information but we would really be able
to have a complete data set attached to
each specimen that we give that fits the
needs of the PI's so that's kind of
future State and hopes so when we got
lab Vantage what we actually had to do
and really lab Vantage implementation
did not take off until our Institute
realized that we need people to support
it and when we talked to the other
Hospital to use it they're using between
a team of five and seven people just to
support lab Vantage and it makes sense
because it's kind of like Co pop or any
other Institute wide system so we were
able to hire a lead systems analyst
who's also computer programmer to data
analysts who have been very instrumental
in going out and assessing the labs that
were onboarding and onboarding the other
labs and then technical analysts which
includes a lot of our computer
programmers and this has been it's been
very very helpful so getting back to the
vision and the IT standpoint with lab
Vantage like I said we went live January
1 of this year lab managed does
currently communicate with epic in a
limited fashion so what that means is
when we have a specimen that comes in we
scan the requisition on that specimen
and it uploads the pieces of basic
demographic information and Auto
populates those fields and lab Vantage
so that includes like the name the date
of birth the medical record number the
gender the ethnicity I believe so that
stuff Auto populates which is great
because it reduces
the room for human air in an increases
efficiency CCC B is like I said
onboarding other institutions and
principal investigators gradually and
our analysts are helping to do that and
we wanted to communicate with all these
other systems so the next aspect of the
vision is to get samples processed by
standard procedures based on expert
recommendations so whether you get a
sample you know from from anywhere or
any year time point you know it's
processed the same way and we really
want it Brooks and Brooks has started to
assist us with this because they have a
long track record of being the bio bank
for a lot of different big data projects
so they will assist in creating these
policies and procedures which will be
uploaded for everyone to see and will
become universal throughout the
enterprise phase one is really verifying
and registering or current inventory in
that process for instance you develop a
screening protocol so first off anything
that's not labeled gets discarded and
then you start to decide what are your
second priority so you know random
checks on on specimen integrity from
different years from different places in
the freezer these are the sorts of
things that we're looking at what's
worth keeping and what do we actually
have and phase two would be moving all
low touch specimens off-site to the
off-site location where Brooke the
building that Brooks will run and so
these specimen the low touch specimens
are yet to be defined but pretty much
it's going to be anything that's not a
reagent that or any sample that's not
going to be used immediately because the
turnaround time to retrieve specimens is
at 24 hours and we hope that many people
choose to work would be enterprise
although we can't force people to give
up their freezers we hope that they see
that they don't really want to carry a
pager for 24 hours a day and seven days
a week in case their breather goes down
or if they're not currently carrying a
pager they don't want to worry about
whether their freezer went down and they
didn't know it and they really are not
as good as they think they are at
keeping and storing specimens because
bio banking you know is a job in and of
itself and it's not necessarily the
science that these people are good at
they need more time to be reading the
literature designing experiments
analyzing data writing papers etc and so
we may eventually need a cold search
policy with teeth but we're hoping that
everyone chooses when they see the cap
accreditation and the ease of use to
work with with the central biorepository
and with Brooks so we're starting to
inventory the Cleveland Clinic freezers
we distributed files to the Lerner
Research Institute department admins
they completed an inventory they we
reconciled that inventory with a ledger
from facilities engineering of all the
freezers in the in the departments we're
working with additional admins to fill
the list and really we want to complete
this process with the help of Brooks and
accompany walk through in the winter of
this year next year
so the off-site storage was important as
part of the vision and like I said
that's where we're working with Brooks I
can show you now that we are going to be
building a building that essentially
sits across the street from the clinical
pathology laboratory building and the
Lerner Research Institute on innovation
corridor which has been you know
something that once that the leaders of
Cleveland of the city want to develop
and it's going to be a twenty twenty-one
thousand square foot building two floors
about ten and a half thousand on each
floor it will have another footprint of
8,000 or so expansion area and a parking
lot and on Cedar Avenue so this is what
it's going to look like it's going to
house -80 freezers liquid nitrogen
freezers there's going to be a blood
processing area as well as the blood
draw station and a research access
center and we'll get into the research
access Center a little bit later so the
it was important for us to engage the
community to get approval for this
building to be built what we actually
had to purchase a residence home in
order to build it we had to work with
churches and so forth and so we want to
it's been important that we express to
the community that one of the purposes
of the bio Bank really a major purpose
of the bio bank is to to get samples
from this community to study and solve
problems that they're facing with their
health and so we designed the research
access center that will be visible at
the entry to the building to really
showcase the types of research that are
going on and in a translated version
that the lay public can understand to
give health fairs to give journal clubs
and research talks we're also partnering
with local school
we have Stokes interns which come from
the local high school and do summer
internships in different labs and with
the Cleveland Clinic to learn about
future careers in research and in
healthcare we'll be organizing
educational tours about bio banking and
the building with different religious
and civic and school groups like I said
we want a blood draw space so if people
want to donate blood for research we can
they don't have to you know go and pay
to park and try and find something
buried inside the Cleveland Clinic they
can just pull up and come here
we also want to work with other hospital
systems youh university hospitals of
Cleveland which is associated with keep
Western and Metro hospitals are also big
hospitals in
learner so a big hospital systems within
Cleveland and so basically they want to
increase the foot traffic between the
community and Cleveland in a scientific
scientifically enriching way that
benefits us in them and also they want
to build some some shops around here so
Starbucks Panera etc
and here's an example of the sorry the
Louis Stokes some of the Louis Stokes
scholars that we've had and here just
shows that we have a clinical research
unit but that's again buried inside the
the center of the hospital so we really
want the blood processing lab in this
bio Bank facility to work with the
clinical research unit and so the last
aspect of the vision really is the
governance for access but what I'd like
to to stress with that if when we really
haven't talked about that as as much yet
because we need to get the specimens
guarantee their integrity classify and
be able to report on them first but what
I've noticed and some of you probably
experiences as well is that when you
start a biobank oftentimes people think
it's committers their their eyes are
bigger than their stomachs so they think
that they want to do all this and
they're really they don't want to share
specimens they're worried about other
people taking their specimens so forth
and so on but there's often more than
enough to go around and if we get to a
point where we've got well characterized
specimen sets that people are arguing
over I think and that we need to govern
for access I think then we're in the
place we want to be I always say you
can't call it a bank without withdrawals
so moving on kind of when you look at
the current to future States I just sort
of want to summarize this so say that
you know you have an investigator who
requires 300 blood samples from healthy
participants to be tested for you know a
lot value X for instance cholesterol and
that the samples must be for men and
they must be between the ages of 40 and
60 and they must have never taken drug
why well in the currency we would need
physicians to identify recruit scheduled
consent and
courage to show up and draw blood for
300 men fitting this category and so II
research would have to identify those
you'd have to send out letters to them
inviting them to participate you'd have
to send its estimated 5,000 letters to
get 3,000 people to participate then you
have a study coordinator call them
follow up explain the study determine
interest deal with many machines phone
calls etc have them come in and then you
know sample handle eyes the handling and
processing so so give to the lab get the
results then pull all the other
associated data and it costs a lot of
money costs on they've estimated $32,000
and the study would take 9 to 12 months
just for one project but in the future
state patients would be consented
electronically with the universal
consent maybe first they would be a you
know approached for universal consent by
their surgeon or by you know but
eventually future state they would be
approached in my chart electronically be
able to think it over read the
information in their own home
voluntarily opt in and then we would be
able to search who is opted in and then
who myths meets these requirements we'd
get a notification when those Bloods
were drawn and then we would go grab the
samples and really it would be free and
it would happen a lot more quickly and
the future state really makes a big data
possible and sustainable so we need IT
and computers to automate IRB driven
hypothesis driven specimen searches with
matching clinical data otherwise there's
too much hands-on work Universal consent
allows us to interrogate genomic data
which is essential for for precision
medicine and a universal Cleveland
Clinic biorepository allows us to get
the numbers that are needed
to really look at the interplay of
genomics and different disease and
response to treatment and so at this
time I'd like to open it up for
questions that anybody might have or
that might have sent in
you
okay yes thank you dr. Koh for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located at the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for okay dr. Koh let's start with
question number one what is the most
important component of bio banking at
the Cleveland Clinic so I would say
there's two so but first I think is
working together working together with
the different institutions so as a
pathologist
you know we recognize that the NCI for
instance it's NCI best practices for for
bio banks to be housed within pathology
and we are an integral part of deciding
what tissue is appropriate for research
and we've long been in the practice of
cataloging samples characterizing
samples the data attached to those
samples but we also need help from
clinicians we need help from the
different Institute's we need help from
the Research Institute and there are a
lot of at a place like this there is so
much work to go around that everybody
needs to to do their part and there is
so much wealth to go around that the
perception that you know one person is
going to use all of the samples or steal
from everybody else it is just wrong and
so I think being very transparent and
being very I had to gain a lot of trust
I think when I came into this position
that but nobody is the your specimens
are going to be available to you they're
not going to be given to anybody else
and so forth so there are a lot of
politics but I think if everybody is
working towards the same cause and
really has the best interests at heart
you can overcome that and
and I'd say the second most important
piece is IT we are only as good as our
computer and in this day and age and the
data is so immense that we need the
computers not only to really track the
data well and be able to tell us what we
have and in the quality of what we have
but also to to get consent of patients
to identify patients that are targeted
for collections I see a time when in the
future when someone comes to me and a
researcher comes to me who's studying
basic science prostate cancer and says I
need you know blood from this many
prostate patients and then I can sort of
go into our files see how many patients
have been diagnosed with prostate cancer
if I need specific attributes there can
be a search on copass but then the
automated part comes where every night
once you've got that list of MRN you can
actually be procuring on a regular basis
by feeding from lab Vantage to Sunglass
each night do you have a match do you
have this patient that we're looking for
did they come through did they have a
blood draw and then you get a report the
next day and says oh you know these
criteria that you've programmed in to
come to me every night is here and
here's where it's located and now you
just go get it but as long as we're
doing everything manually it's not going
to be sustainable and with at a hospital
system like this with reimbursement
going down set by CMS I think that you
know we all know that research is going
to be the first thing on the chopping
block and so you've got to get more
efficient and the only way to get more
efficient is to use computers okay so
here we've got a question which is what
is the financing model for keeping
freezers and low touch inventory
off-site so that's a good question right
now the money has been given to the
startup money for this has been given to
the learner Research Institute as a part
of one of their innovations initiatives
the hope is that we will be able to to
basically recover that cost when
investigators right in the cost so
instead of writing in the cost to store
themselves they would write in the cost
to store off-site with with this
off-site location into their grants and
into their proposals but we understand
that's going to be a gradual process and
then it requires some startup money from
the Research Institute but we we hope
that it would be all that it will be
worth it because investigators and their
research personnel will be able to work
to the top of their licensure and to be
worth working with very high quality
specimens and we also hope that this
encourages collaboration so once
patients have signed universal consent
we will be able to be in a place where
if you've collected a hundred samples
and you've used a lakh watts of those
for your study and you no longer require
them you or maybe you you can open up
those samples to be visible and
available to other investigators and the
annotation that you've already done with
them even from an experimental
standpoint also becomes available to
other investigators and then they have
the opportunity to utilize and look at
that data and utilize whatever sample
remains in a different way
and it's a win-win situation really
because it's a collaboration it's better
use of the sample and I see
increased visibility will increase I
like to think of it as a Renaissance
period you know increased trade and and
everybody wins so that's another thing
that we're hoping comes from this
alright I've got another question how do
you handle FFPE samples that are 10
years old or older that kept us to be
destroyed or completely be identified
for laboratory purposes so my
understanding was cap is that they are
required to be kept for 10 years but
whether or not they're destroyed after
that or de-identified after that is
really up to you so like we're required
to keep things for 10 years on main
campus but we often keep them much much
longer and I know that some of our
satellite hospitals which were formerly
Community Hospital's were in the process
are were in the habit of destroying FFPE
blocks at the end of 10 years because it
was more economical but there's nothing
that says that they had to be destroyed
they were choosing to destroy this so
what we've actually done is tried to
recuperate a lot of the ones that our
regional hospitals would be destroying
bring them down to main campus sort
through them and see which ones are very
valuable that we want to actually keep
in our archives and de-identified we D
identify them when they're needed for
research which we do would do anyway if
there was no consent so we're not
required to di that word be honest
Berger because we're within pathology
and so we would be identify them before
sending them out to the investigator and
then how many samples are incurrent ly
storing in the bio repository so that's
one of the problems that number is hard
to get at each freezer we know can store
around 50,000 samples and there are an
estimated 400 freezers around the
enterprise
so you can do the math for that but we
what we're in the process of figuring
out is how full are all those freezers
I'm pretty sure they're not awful so
whatever number you get with that you
probably divide in half and that's about
how many we have but the agreement as at
least as it stands with Brooks is that
we would be obligated to fill 167
freezers in the off-site storage
facility for 10 years Brooks will be
working with other people like
University Hospitals as I mentioned
Metro and and also have other clients
besides just Cleveland Clinic okay so
what measures are you taking to analyze
flash
ensure integrity of samples for genomic
studies so DNA RNA degradation over the
time that might affect analysis outcome
so we've had summer students that have
done projects on this looking at RNA and
DNA integrity actually we sent these
samples to Brooks to get their analysis
and make perhaps I can give another web
dollar just reporting some of this with
more concrete data looking at the
integrity of DNA and RNA in different
tissue types over different time points
and both cancerous and non cancerous
tissue and actually what we found I was
surprised because I thought that RNA was
basically worthless after a certain
amount of time but that's not
necessarily true we found that there was
more variability based on tissue type
than there were was based on year of of
banking and so that's why I think that
we really need to go through these
specimens more laborious Lee than just
throwing away all specimens before a
certain year because our data would
indicate that the even you know 10 20
year old frozen samples have good DNA
and RNA integrity depending on the
tissue type and most likely a lot of the
is related to pre-processing variables
things that are out of our control
unfortunately some of that is warm
ischemia time so when the tissues in the
patient what's going on with that
patient what's their blood pressure like
are they acidotic are they have they
been clamped off for too long
the blood flow to the tissue before it's
removed secondly how those tissues are
processed
uniformly within pathology for instance
breast tissue
depending on the size can be buried in a
lot of fat which can Otto lies over time
if they're the tissue is an inked
immediately and sectioned properly and
then you know tissue grabbed for
research and then fixed and perfect so
just like what you see with FFP a tissue
there's some variability and like tissue
and how it's how quickly it's likely to
be processed and that's why we're
getting more into tracking all the
coldest Kimia time having a dedicated PA
that has to prioritize all the research
specimens and get them processed
immediately so if we take those
variables out I believe that samples
will have good RNA DNA integrity for
many years so ethics what ethics
problems do you anticipate so we're
we've seen a little bit of us I think
which gets into the so for a long time I
guess I would say that the Cleveland
Clinic was like the wild wild west so
you know you've got a lot of fiefdom
Institute's and research groups who are
doing their own things and maybe they
would be working with different
companies or maybe they wanted and there
was separate IRB approval and separate
law review and and separate MTA's and I
think what we're seeing is that we we
that's not the way that we're going to
go we're going to go to full
transparency around the Institute and
the institution so part of that is
what's everybody doing
um and you know who is really the
governing body so that gets into that
governance piece who is the governing
body the Cleveland Clinic owns the
samples it's not the surgeon at this
point now it may change and become the
patient but at this point the Cleveland
Clinic owns all samples so it's not the
surgeon who removes the samples it's not
the pathologist who signs out the case
and so really if anybody is going to
make addy it makes some kind of
agreement with those samples it has to
be representing the Cleveland Clinic on
the whole not just one person not just
one Institute so that's number one
number two we would like to sort of
acknowledge and spread the culture that
samples that would otherwise be thrown
in the trash or incinerated have a high
value to discovering and curing disease
and I you know I say that to everybody
that I talked to while you may walk
question the ethics of us using residual
samples for research I question the
ethics of us throwing those samples in
the garbage when they could be used
towards life-saving treatment and so I
think it starts with spreading the
culture in your hospital that you accept
that this is your ethical obligation to
advance research which ultimately helps
treat disease so it is for the patients
then you kind of spread that ethics to
your community and that idea to your
community look this is like recycling
this is not being wasteful this is an N
full disclosure you know full disclosure
we would love to consent our goal is to
consent every patient
Cleveland Clinic patient and have and
give them a chance patients really do
want to participate because they know
that it could help you know not only
them but their offspring especially
people with genetic diseases and so
forth and so on
so I think it's a lot of it as a
cultural thing and we have to be the
champions of that and then you know just
just be being honest and saying look you
know we have to recoup cause
this gives the sustainability for the
work that we're doing for this research
but all the costs gets reinvested into
the research and the work related to
that research and it's part of the
sustainability so that's how I would
approach that now here I've got a
question rather than individual manual
freezers have you considered the Brooks
automated bio stores so I'm not that
familiar with the automated bio stores
so maybe I should become so I'm assuming
that means robotics so before my time
when I was not the medical director they
did have this idea that they wanted to
collect blood on everybody who came
through the Cleveland Clinic and to do
that you would need robotics and it
would need to be automated and at the
time the person before me worked out the
cost for all of that presented it to the
executive leadership and there was no
money for it
and so we haven't looked at something at
that level yet I really think the
Cleveland Clinic culture is to start
with what you're given show what you can
do of it and then they'll give you money
and you grow so we're kind of starting
with what we've been given and we hope
to really show what we can do with it
and I think the best way to do that is
target particular disease groups and and
you know patients going to surgery etc
um now I have a question see here hold
on
it's it I don't know okay in the
pharmaceutical industry we must validate
the installation qualification operation
performance our freezers and have a
robust collaboration and maintenance
program for each to ensure examples are
not qualified or compromised
additionally the software for control
has similar requirements do you have
this for your repository - so that's
part of the issue right we want to
collaborate with pharmaceutical industry
we're not currently in a position we do
in the central biorepository koala
fire instruments in our freezers we just
got the software which is lab managed
which will be this you know qualified
but what but all the other samples are
not in a position to do that except
probably select a lab which either are
functioning as bio banks for the NIH or
select but we have one research lab that
actually has CLIA certification in the
Lerner Research Institute and so that's
part of the deal is to harmonize and
validate qualify everything with the
help and assistance of Brooks so that we
are in a position to to collaborate with
pharmaceutical industry
thank you dr. Koh do you have any final
comments for audience I don't you can
always feel free to email me if you have
any other questions or ideas ko j2 at
Cleveland Clinic org or at CCS so it's
for Cleveland Clinic foundation but it's
letter c letter c letter s org if you
have any collaboration ideas and so
forth and that's it thank you again to
dr. Jennifer Koh for her time today and
her important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Brooks life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd also like to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions
that we did not have time to answer
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
dr. Koh via the contact information that
you provided at the time of registration
now this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through june of 2019 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye
Oh